Scott you were the reviewer for
Dishonored 2 for us and you quite liked
the game it's fantastic it's a really
really great game um and yeah people
yelling me in the comments are not
giving it a 9 like I gave a so give it
an eight out of 10 wait wait people are
being rude from the comments I know
right then what about you rented you
wouldn't believe unheard of behavior so
so tell me you know what is
fundamentally different this time around
about the game sure um to be completely
honest it's not drastically different
from the first game I mean it still
plays on all of the same major pillars
it is both a stealth and action games
simultaneously it allows you to play
either way feels fully fleshed out and
robust I mean they've certainly added
new options for both play styles since
the original game but the the core like
the fundamentals of what makes
dishonored work are the same as they
were in the first game so that's like
player creativity being able to approach
situations from different angles um you
know high chaos vs lo que haces
basically killing people or not killing
people there's so story-driven ways to
deal with all of your major targets so a
lot of the principles the guy did the
first game are still present in this
game but there's a new protagonist Emily
called win who was very young in the
previous game she's now aged 15 years
and she's the second playable
protagonists and has her own set of
powers so you can still plays Corvo the
original hero and still have all
original powers but now you can place
Emily as well so they've definitely
added stuff without fundamentally
altering what the game is so do those
two characters feel like really
different and obviously the power sets
are different but like in practice you
know like in terms of how you approach a
mission do you feel like it's worth
playing as both yes and no I mean to me
what's more interesting about the
choosing how you play is is going loud
or going silent like that to me is a
much bigger decision Emily in corvo in
most ways are identical like movements
and basic melee things like that are
essentially identical between the two
characters the biggest differences are
the powers that they have access to but
even those they're often analogous
powers like for example kokoro has
blinked so he can teleport around and
emily has far reach which functions very
similarly in Lazar to access distant
places so it really depends on like what
power sound interesting too
you and if you've played the first game
definitely check out Emily because all
of her powers are super cool and clearly
learned lessons from things people
wanted out of the first game so you can
like hypnotized enemies with her you can
turn into like a moving shadow and
assassinate people so it just kind of
depends on what sounds interesting to
you the bigger the bigger choice really
is are you gonna try to play stealthy or
you could just kind of like wreak havoc
and that to me is is actually I mean I
talked about this in the review that i
really like stealth games and i
generally will play stealth if that's an
option but messing around in dishonor it
is so much fun like all the different
things you can do there's you know from
throwing people into electrified gates
to you know stopping time and placing
them in front of their own bullets
things like that I mean just the amount
of creativity you can employ while
making your way through the game is kind
of unlike anything else I mean it's not
completely new and we've seen in games
like Bioshock but i think the dishonored
probably does it better than any game
currently available and that that is
what makes it in making an amazing game
Jake how did you play I know you played
a lot as well you stealthy so my main
game I mostly play stealthy like that
that's how I play again like when I can
I always do stilt but I late why it's
more satisfying okay I think it's more
satisfying it takes a lot longer though
but to be honest I've played through at
least the first five missions maybe like
six or seven times now just for like
capturing different things and I've
played stealth I played assault I played
high chaos i played low chaos and like
Scott was saying like whatever you play
you're probably going to have fun but I
think maybe don't play at five times but
I think this game really shines when you
start playing in a second time because
then you feel more comfortable with the
with what you can do and your powers in
like different pathways yeah its second
time is so much fun it's definitely a
learning curve like once you kind of
understand how the game operates and
what you can kind of do within the
confines of the world you start to have
a lot more fun like the first couple
hours actually I almost didn't enjoy the
game because i was just so like but
we'll dirt and frustrated and like
couldn't do exactly what i wanted to do
and then finally figured out like okay
this is kind of how this game just works
and once I kind of got into it it really
opens up and yeah if you're able and
willing to put in that time up front
you're absolutely rewarded the initial
investment and you were saying though in
your review like at the end of the game
you felt
as though that you had kind of mastered
all of your tools and the game didn't
didn't meet you halfway it didn't
continue to ramp up the challenge or
offer like a new scenario that you just
hadn't encountered before can you gues
describe that a little bit like why I
always want to expand on this because
this was this was something that was
difficult to articulate in something
that I think a lot of people took issue
with in the comment so I'm gonna do my
best to like explain it more thoroughly
now because it was it was hard like I
hate seeing in comments people being
like I don't understand this point or
like right I don't understand this
criticism because that means that I kind
of failed in that at least in that
portion of the review so the best way I
can explain it is as you play the game
you're gathering runes your unlocking
new powers you're upgrading pretty
consistently you don't have to like you
can ignore powers completely if you want
but part of what makes the game fun is
unlocking new powers and seeing what you
can do with them to me that's kind of
like the engine that drives the entire
experience forward so as you do that as
you unlock these new things you are
inevitably becoming more and more
powerful you can do more stuff the stuff
you can do is leveled up and has a
bigger impact on the world is simply
more powerful so your character is kind
of on an upward arc throughout the
entire experience and the game the
difficulty in the challenge is also on
an upward arc but it doesn't quite keep
pace with your growth as a character so
by the end I felt like my level of power
head exceeded the challenge presented by
the game and and I don't mean oh I
wasn't dying enough or oh I wanted to
like you know take more damage from
enemies and you know deal less damage to
them I just mean like I wish there had
been more scenarios that it challenged
me in new ways intellectually right yeah
like so I have these all these new
powers give me new things to do with
them present me with new situations
where I have to rethink the things I've
been doing all game because by the end I
was actually thinking less about what I
was doing because I was so much more
easily able to make my way through
things and I feel like you should kind
of be the inverse so again that's that's
difficult to explain if you haven't made
it through the end I had a bunch of
people be like I played the first five
hours this game is brilliant I'm like
talk to me when you get to our 16
because it's not like the game gets bad
I just wish there had been more of a
culmination I wish that all the
different things that have been thrown
at you kind of came together in like
really grand challenge at the end that
really
do you rethink the way you've been
playing the game or challenge you to use
all of your different options sort of in
concert with one another in a new way
yeah anything like that and it's like
the game fails to do that I just wish it
had done it more and part what what sort
of compounds this problem is that
there's no sort of new game + option so
by the time you make it to the end and
by the time you've unlocked all these
powers you really only have like one
maybe two levels in which to use those
powers because you can't backtrack it's
true and we use the stuff you've
unlocked so if like hey I have this cool
new tool like I have this thing I
unlocked it I want to try you only have
a really short amount of time to
actually do it that's run out of game
then there's no way to go back like
right if you've saved at every level you
can go replay a level on a higher
difficulty but you still don't have the
new powers that you earned by the end of
the game so you get to the end and
you've unlocked all these powers and
then you're just done and they're just
gone and it's like that's kind of
unsatisfying it's so again it's like
this is a massive failing on the game's
part but it's something that I found to
be a bit of a letdown when I've made it
to the end so that to me is part of why
I sward n and I did grapple with the
score like I absolutely flirted with the
idea of giving in a 9 but this
discussion is in part why lower the
score the other big reason is the story
but I feel like I've kind of droned on a
lot about the game already so we can get
in the story if you want but Jay Galle
you have a question that is one of the
big problems criticisms but I guess what
the first one was that the ending kind
of like punished you if you chose to
play hi chaos now obviously don't spoil
anything but like does the ending feel
like you're being punished if you play a
certain way it didn't know not really
although interestingly the game at least
from a narrative standpoint goes out of
its way to encourage you to play stealth
and there's nothing mechanically forcing
you to you're not really punished but at
the very beginning of the game the
outsider who's this character who gives
you your powers in the first place has
some line rings like are you clever
enough to save the world without
spilling a river of blood like sort of
goading you into playing stealthily yeah
and there are sort of narrative
consequences for for playing hi chaos
but i don't remember they're really
being any in might sort of like to play
throughs no i don't think i was really
punished or like it was yeah you know
first one it's like you killed too many
people rats took over the city and
everyone's dead
it's like so that that right does kind
of happen so the game absolutely changes
both the narrative and the world itself
change depending on how many people
you've killed so in this game rather
than rats it's blood flies who are like
flies that spawn in the bodies like in
dead bodies so you'll see more of them
but they're also not like a huge threat
so it kind of makes it more difficult to
access certain areas but generally there
are no areas that are completely blocked
off it's just like oh you've now made
your own life more difficult it doesn't
close doors it just like pushes them
later you know it make it just makes
your life a little trickier that's all
so it's not really a punishment it's
just like feels like an actual
consequence for the way you've chosen to
play the game so I really like the way
that the game handles that actually I
think that's it's really impressive the
way that they sort of scale the
experience depending on how you've
chosen to play okay a final quick
question any differences on ps4 pro did
united again ps4 pro I know the people
were having some trouble on PC and I
played the game on ps4 so I apologize to
PC gamers who may have wanted insight
into their particular platform but my
understanding is those problems weren't
didn't necessarily affect everybody and
many of those have already been resolved
so apologies to PC players if you were
experiencing issues but with any luck
the game the game itself when it's
functioning as it should is excellent
and by all accounts it is functioning as
it should for most PC players at this
point so apologies for not pointing that
out to PC players last week as to in
terms of ps4 pro hopefully we'll have a
chance to sit down and play that a bit
this week haven't had a chance so far so
unfortunately I can't weigh in yet
alright no worries thank you for all
your thoughts on that game Dishonored 2
is out now you go check it out make sure
to check out Scott's review on gamespot
com and the video review on YouTube and
leave us some comments let us know what
you think